Hi all, my name's Josh Livni,
and I work on the developer
relations team here at Google.
Today I want to show you how to
add a new dimension to your
map by integrating Google
Earth in just
four lines of code.
First, let's take a look at a
basic maps API example that
we'd like to add a 3D view to.
Here I have a basic map that
I've taken from the maps V3
examples page which has
a simple KML layer.
I replaced the KML overlay of
the Chicago transit with this
track of my snowboard route
from Squaw Valley last
weekend, which I recorded and
shared using the My Tracks
application on Android.
It's been a bad year at the
CRS, not much fresh now.
Can you tell if I stuck to the
groomers in these conditions?
Not really, because even with
the satellite view enabled
it's hard to get a feel
for the mountain.
So let's edit the code here to
first include the generic
Google API loader, which we'll
do in this script tag.
For those of you familiar with
Earth API development, you'll
note that I have not specified
a domain-specific API key in
the loader.
And this is because since the
launch last year of Google
Earth Version 6, the API key
has not been required.
Next we'll load up the
third-party utility library
that takes care of the maps
and Earth integration.
I'm loading a local copy, and
there's a link to the library
at the end of the
presentation.
And now let's load up the Earth
API itself, which we do
by simply calling Google.load
Earth, and
then the version one.
The Google loader, by the way,
can also load up a variety of
other APIs, as well as hosted
libraries like jQuery.
Check it out at
developers.google.com/loader.
OK, moving on now.
With three of our four lines
already done, let's finally
add that Earth button
to our mashup.
I'll do this down at the end
of our existing code by
instantiating a new Google Earth
object and pausing at
the map instance we want
to associate it with.
So let's refresh our map.
And look, we have an Earth
button at the top right in the
controls, and clicking it will
load up the Earth API.
Which, as you can see,
gives a much nicer
context to these tracks.
Let's make these tracks seem
a bit more impressive.
This bit takes advantage of the
fact that you can control
the full experience of the
Earth API using the hand
[? loader ?] at the Google
Earth library returns.
Here, for example, I've
modified the terrain
exaggeration programmatically.
But you could also turn on the
historical imagery, and
generally take full advantage
of all the powerful features
of Google Earth to help ensure
your map tells the story the
way you want.
Currently, this maps Earth
integration library supports
all the basic overlays,
including markers, polylines,
polygons, circles, rectangles,
and of course KML.
So that's it for the intro to
quickly bringing Google Earth
to your Maps V3 application.
If you have some data that could
use the rich context of
a 3D view, this library is a
simple way to get started.
Have fun.